I'm the CEO of ember technologies and
we're creating a web application called
Emblaze to allow writers bloggers anyone
who's trying to publish an e-book to
seamlessly integrate their prose with
media I would say any resource that you
can possibly think of is available here
at project Olympus or at Carnegie Mellon
they connect you with anyone they know
there are so many training programs the
connects lectures are absolutely
invaluable if you want an
entrepreneurial education the program
that affected me the most was the
innovation Scholars Program it was
basically a two-year mini MBA program
that took everything that I could have
spent the next six years in the real
world learning networking and how to
start a business and who to contact and
how to keep them all together and it
condensed it down into really practical
hands-on lessons we have a competition
here called hack a startup and basically
you get 72 hours to build from scratch
from idea stage to business plan and
prototype a company about halfway
through I was leading the team and I
just felt like it wasn't there we
weren't gonna make it it wasn't gonna be
good at all and I went to kit and I was
like I think I'm gonna go home I just
it's just not there and she looked at me
and she was like no you're gonna get
yourself back in there and she basically
picked me up and was like go back there
and you take on that challenge and we
ended up winning the hack to startup
it's the community of doers everyone
here is doing something they take the
theory and they apply it to something
practical to solve a problem and that
research that ingenuity is what attracts
entrepreneurs here
you